We have now learned that Jared Kushner, Donald
Trump's son in law, made a deal with Russia
for ventilator's during the Corona virus crisis
in order to be able to say, hey, we've gotten
ventilators, we've got ventilators.
It turns out every single ventilator we got
from Russia was faulty.
According to a new report, every aspect of
this story is crazy.
So, first of all, it's crazy that Jared Kushner,
Donald Trump's son in law, is working in the
administration.
It's insane for reasons of nepotism.
It's insane for reasons of Kushner's incompetence.
Then you might remember that at some point
in maybe it was April or May out or now they
trotted out Jared Kushner to do a Corona virus
press briefing.
And it went horribly wrong.
We never saw him again.
This was the briefing where Kushner dropped
this Kafka esque line of, you know, the ventilator
supply as our supply.
It's not the state's supply, which is like,
you know, we discussed that in detail at the
time.
It was indecipherable, evil, genius, and we
never saw him again at the press briefings.
But even more importantly, some of the things
that Kushner was doing were laughably counterproductive.
So, for example, Kushner organized getting
a shipment of ventilator's.
Russia to the U.S. in late March.
They were faulty.
They didn't work.
Andrew Cuomo got some of them.
Other officials got them.
And they started seeing supplies come in from
Russia and they were wondering why are we
getting Russian supplies?
And the ventilators were faulty.
Jared Kushner was able to hurry up the delivery
of faulty ventilators because he has a personal
relationship with the CEO of a Russian sovereign
wealth fund currently sanctioned by the United
States.
So another insane detail.
Kushner, Godus, faulty ventilators more quickly
by doing business with a Russian dude who's
currently under sanction by the United States.
Every aspect of this is insane.
Then they gave the ventilator's to officials
in New York and New Jersey, including Andrew
Cuomo.
The official said these don't work.
And initially they said, well, it's just that
there's a voltage issue because these are
Russian ventilators.
Once we fix the voltage voltage issue, it'll
be fine.
Turns out that wasn't true.
The ventilators were completely faulty and
this would be a comedy of errors if people's
lives weren't depending on it.
The shipment from Russia.
Let's listen to this insanity.
The shipment from Russia came with other supplies
that weren't even hospital supplies.
Like, for example, Trump talks about getting
gloves.
We're talking about surgical gloves, medical
grade gloves.
Russia sent us household cleaning gloves.
Understand that.
OK, just household cleaning gloves and Russia
build the U.S. six hundred thousand dollars
for those gloves in the middle of a 100 year
pandemic for which Donald Trump was completely
unprepared.
He starts buying faulty incorrect medicine,
medical supplies from Russia.
Now, there are also reports of more than 50
million dollars worth of contaminated corona
virus tests from the United Arab Emirates.
So the reason we elected this guy was supposedly
that a businessman would do really well running
the country.
Now, Trump is a failed businessman.
OK, but this is how it all works.
And quite frankly, this is all seeming more
like money laundering than anything else.
Now, back to the Russian ventilator's for
a second.
Russia sent us 45 Fonte faulty ventilators
around April one, which we paid for.
We later heard news that the Trump administration
was sending Putin 200 of our ventilator's
as part of a foreign aid like we just gave
them to him.
So think about that.
We buy 50 ventilator's or 45 ventilator's
from Russia, which are faulty.
And then we give them 200 of our ventilator's,
which work well.
This is how a businessman runs the country.
Is it money laundering?
Is it embezzlement?
And this is just one story among hundreds
like this in this administration.
We may never know the full reality of it.
And you know what?
If we get rid of them, I don't care if we
never know the full reality of every single
one of these stories.